today on the matt wall show tim tebow is
getting another crack at the nfl but
colin kaepernick isn't
the media says this is evidence of
racism i say it's evidence of
something else also five headlines
including hackers shut down a major u.s
pipeline and the gop says that
we need to get mothers back to work is
that the right messaging is that
conservative messaging also
is a horse the latest victim of cancel
culture we have to talk about that and
speaking of cancelling in our daily
cancellation we'll deal with the
morbid morbidly obese model in quotes
there
who now says she has anorexia they just
don't make anorexics like they used to
we'll talk about that and much more
today on the matte wall show
yesterday we began the show by talking
about the many millionaire and
billionaire celebrities who are being
horrifically oppressed
in this country it's a big problem
michelle obama principal among them a
woman who says you know she fears
walking down the street
because of all the racist cops out there
prowling around she also says
she was in line for ice cream once and a
white woman cut in front of her
accidentally
these are the kinds of deprivations and
persecutions that she has suffered oprah
lebron james meghan markle
and others uh join her in the ranks of
extraordinarily wealthy and powerful
victims but i feel a little embarrassed
today because while
listing all of the most prominent and
profitable victims in america
today i somehow neglected to mention the
greatest of them all the man who will
surely take center
stage on the mount rushmore of
self-victimizing millionaire bratz
and that would be of course colin
kaepernick colin kaepernick a former nfl
bench writer who decided to start
protesting injustice at exactly the
moment
when his nfl career was going off the
rails
interesting timing then when he failed
out of the league after a c
after a season where he went one in ten
as a starter
he started to uh started a new career as
a professional activist
that career has been far more successful
and profitable than his playing career
by a large margin he's had deals with
netflix nike many other major companies
released his own shoe gotten a book deal
a movie deal
and all the while he's being hailed as a
martyr for the cause
i mean what cause exactly well that was
never made exactly
clear originally we were told that his
kneeling during the anthem was a protest
against police brutality not against the
flag itself or the country but then a
few years ago
nike released a shoe or tried to release
a shoe with an american flag on it
and kaepernick complained so he didn't
want he didn't want there to be a shoe
with a flag on it and they recalled the
shoe now apparently
i guess he does have a problem with the
flag itself
what could his problem possibly be i
mean how could he
hate a country that's made him rich and
famous beyond
the wildest dreams of normal people and
giving him all this wealth and fame
despite the fact that he's produced
nothing of value really nothing at all
and actually flunked out of his chosen
field
how is that possible well these are all
good questions and we have another
chance to think about these questions
now that kaepernick
is back in the news reading out from the
daily wired says as tim tebow awaits a
possible one-year contract to play for
the jacksonville jaguars
progressives on twitter have excoriated
the nfl for leaving former 49ers
quarterback colin kaepernick
out in the cold as daly wire reported on
monday ian rappaport of nfl insider
announced that
tebow stands on the cusp of signing with
jacksonville jaguars and reuniting with
his former mentor
uh he's tweeted quote the jaguars are
planning to sign qb turn
tight end tim tebow to a one-year deal a
deal that could be official in next week
or so nothing done yet but it'll have a
chance to make the team
to reunite with his mentor and college
head coach urban meyer so it's a chance
to
make the team he's not actually on the
team yet but back to us to the articles
as kaepernick fans many of whom feel the
nfl blackballed him in response to his
national anthem protests in the name of
black lives matter
did not welcome the news quote
interesting how the same people that are
praising tim tebow for his values
outside of football see colin
kaepernick's values as a distraction
that according to ahmed ali another one
says there's no way you can
tell me that tim tebow deserves to be on
a team as an unproven tight end who
hasn't played in nine years more than
colin kaepernick
there's just no way that's going to make
sense that according to david dennis jr
there was plenty more reactions along
those lines all from the usual suspects
including jameel hill and others of
course
cory booker a noted nfl analyst chimed
in as well here's what he said
people are saying you know it there's a
little white privilege going on here
you know tim tebow has a different
there's different standards for him
to cast a shadow on tim tebow in order
to
point out the injustice of colin
kaepernick i mean
that is uh it's wrong he was blackballed
uh and i don't need to push somebody
else down in order to
point that out so i just know that he's
gotten an
awful deal it's it's he is an
extraordinary athlete
who had his career sabotaged by people
that were
against him doing what some of the
greatest athletes of all times from
arthur ashton muhammad ali have done
which is speak out against injustice do
you think colin maybe should try a
different position or is that is it just
you think it's it's more than just a
position i think it has nothing to do
with him it has to do with the nfl and
the decisions that were made
just perfect there in that video uh
perfect timing as they're interviewing
cory booker
in nice looks like dc and
a guy jogs by wearing a mask just
absolutely perfect these lunatics these
psychos um anyway these comparisons are
all coming from people who either don't
understand the game of football probably
the case for cory booker or who are
pretending
not to understand tim tebow will be
attending training camp to try out for a
different position
where he will no doubt be a backup and
get paid the minimum salary or close to
it
so he just wants to play the game and
he's willing to do whatever it takes for
a shot at playing the game in contrast
colin kaepernick has shown no interest
in playing at any position
let alone let alone a less glamorous one
as a backup
for comparatively little money in fact
two years ago the nfl held a workout for
kaepernick
in the middle of the 2019 season 25
scouts attended
this was all unprecedented as far as i
know the nfl doesn't usually hold
personal workouts for aging backup
players
in the middle of the season or at any
other time of the year
they certainly didn't do that for tim
tebow i could tell you but
they did it for kaepernick because he'd
call them racist if they didn't
but as it turns out he'll call them
racist even if they do you're racist
if you do racist if you don't that's how
it goes with guys like cabernet cap
bailed on the workout though and instead
held his own media event
where he wore a shirt comparing himself
to a slave
making him the highest paid slave in
history we must say
and he blasted the nfl and roger goodell
the commissioner it was all publicity
stunt
they held the work out for him he
refused to go to it and then did his own
event
in front of in front of the cameras
where he was complaining about the nfl
is that what you do if you really want
to play for the nfl if you want a job in
the nfl
is that what you do they invited you to
the workout there are 25 scouts there
show up show them what you can do
demonstrate a little bit of
professionalism and humility
and you get an offer at least to try out
for a team
but he didn't want to actually play he
still doesn't he never did
he's a con man and a grifter an actor
playing a role and
we have to also say playing it pretty
damned well give him credit for that
but nfl head coaches they don't want
actors
on their sidelines they want players
colin kaepernick is not a player and
doesn't want to be one
he hasn't wanted to be one since he
discovered how much money there was to
be made
pretending to be an activist but there's
another difference too and this is
important
another difference between tebow and
kaepernick
the fans love tim tebow
almost everyone loves tim tebow lots of
people hate colin kaepernick
why is that if you're a very stupid
person
you've probably already shouted it's
racism
because the team tebow he's he's the
white guy that's why they like him
except that the nfl is full of beloved
black athletes
so it's obviously not that the key
difference or one of the key
differences is gratitude
both tebow and kaepernick have lived a
blessed life
they're both wealthy and famous and uh
and
and this country has treated them
extraordinarily well
what people like about tim tebow is that
he seems to be aware of this fact and he
exudes gratitude and humility because of
it
he loves this country and he's grateful
for the opportunities that the country
has afforded him
this is an attractive quality among all
people
people root for that people like to be
around that kind of
attitude kaepernick on the other hand
is sullen spoiled ungrateful
this country has given him everything
but it's never enough
he always demands more not because he's
earned it but because
he feels entitled to it he's a
self-victimizing drama queen
a rich whiny entitled complainer now his
his fellow
his fellow rich whiny entitled
complainers in the media
they like that about him because they
can relate to it but it's not the kind
of thing that normal people respect or
want to root for
and it distresses normal people that
this attitude is so common
that there is so little gratitude in
this country
and it is especially absent among the
people who should be
the most displaying it
gratitude that is a a
virtue that's a quality that we're
losing in this country
and we need to regain
tim tebow versus colin kaepernick
perfect example as to why
now let's get to our five headlines
now word from charity mobile i've been a
charity mobile customer myself for
for almost a year now or more and i
couldn't be happier
to be a part of charity mobile because
it's a great service but also
a great cause as well this is a company
that calls itself the pro-life phone
company and for very good reason charity
mobile
will give five percent of your monthly
plan price to the pro-life pro family
charity of your choice which means
that every day living becomes effortless
giving that's the
the slogan over there because that's
what all it is you're paying your bill
you're also donating to a worthy cause
and you're helping to build a culture of
life in america at a time when it's so
desperately needed
but as i said it's also a great service
um new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
you also get there's no contract there's
no termination fees there's no risk with
a 30-day guarantee so you might as well
give charity mobile a shot and i think
you're going to love it a live customer
service based right here in the usa
nationwide service on america's largest
and most reliable 4g lte
network i've never had any problems with
service or anything with charity mobile
so you can call them at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
so starting here number one from the bbc
it says a cyber criminal gang
that took a major u.s fuel pipeline
offline over the weekend has
acknowledged the incident in a public
statement
the group is called darkseid and they
wrote on their website
quote our goal is to make money and not
to create problems for society so
they're saying that they didn't mean to
create
their i don't know this is kind of an
apology in a way
they just they they wanted it was like a
ransom thing and they were trying to
make money they didn't mean to cause
problems
oh well in that case don't worry about
it darkseid
they're saying hey all we did was take
down a major us
fuel line we didn't think it would cause
prop what that causes problems
seriously i had no idea
uh the u.s issued emergency legislation
on sunday after colonial pipeline was
hit by a ransom where cyber attack
pipeline carries 2.5 million barrels a
day
45 of the east coast supply of diesel
patrol
and jet fuel um
that's what dark side there they're
surprised by this
what you mean to tell us if we shut down
45
of the east coast supply of fuel it's
gonna make it's gonna create an issue
it's gonna be a problem
man had no idea sorry about that my bad
the operator took itself offline on
friday after cyber attack
uh after the cyber attack worked to
restore services continuing
on monday the fbi officially confirmed
that darkseid was
responsible for compromising colonial
pipelines networks
saying that it was continuing to work
with the firm and other government
agencies on the investigation
now you read about this and how some
sort of hacking group was able to
infiltrate and take down a major fuel
line
and it might make you kind of concerned
about
what else could they do could they take
down the power grid if they wanted to
but don't worry about it okay don't
worry about this because we know we know
that um
that our intelligence agencies they're
on top of it
the fbi the cia all the intelligence
community they're on top of this
by right by putting out advertisements
uh extolling the virtues of of tolerance
and by you know bringing people on to
the job
because they're because of their gender
identity and so on and so forth
doesn't that doesn't that make you uh
feel pretty comfortable
knowing that our intelligence community
that that's where their priorities are
gender identity tolerance acceptance
diversity
diversity is our number one priority
so while they're focused on that um
we've got cyber criminals taking down
fuel lines
perfect wonderful number two this is
from the
uh there's a tweet here from the gop
official twitter account this is what
they tweeted out
they said 1.5 million u.s mothers have
fallen out of the workforce and many are
staying home to take care of their
children because schools have not
reopened
biden is proving to be a detriment to
getting mothers back to work
this is why the republican party
is awful at messaging and at everything
else
now yes we
we agree that having
millions of people leave the workforce
women or men
is a bad thing and one of the
consequences of having all the schools
shut down
is that yeah now you've got either
people or they've got you got to pay
more for
for child care or you've got to someone
has to stay home and take care of the
kids
and that has been a crisis in a lot of
families
even if i think that in the long term
it's better not to have a public school
system at all
when you take it away all at once like
this it creates
major major problems for families so all
of that is true and
it's okay to point that out you should
be able to point that out
um in a way
that's consistent with conservative
values
because getting mothers back to work
that's not exactly our goal as
conservatives
that's certainly not the way that i
would phrase it
yet we want to get the economy back open
again that's true
and we want people who want to work to
be working
this is just another perfect example
here of the gop
terrible messaging biden is proving to
be a detriment
to getting mothers let's get mothers
back to work
no it's actually all in all it's a it's
a positive thing
to have mothers at home caring for their
children which isn't to say that no
women
should be out working but that's a
positive thing
and so in in presenting it as a negative
like this is a problem we got all these
mothers at home we got to get them back
to work out in that workforce
this is a if if i if it wasn't for the
if it wasn't for
biden the fact that biden was being
attacked here
if you if you didn't know who was in
office and you read that
you would assume that was a tweet from
the democrats
because that's their goal is to get the
mothers back we don't want the mothers
at home we want them out
in we want them in the workforce but as
always very little difference between
the republicans and democrats as we know
uh speaking of biden number three joe
biden addressed
the claim that unemployment is high
right now because people are being paid
to stay at home
and he doesn't see evidence of that but
at the same he doesn't see evidence that
it's a problem but at the same time he
has a plan
for supposedly solving that problem so
i'm not really sure how that makes a lot
of sense but
here is joe biden we're going to make it
clear that anyone collecting
unemployment
who is offered a suitable job
must take the job or lose their
unemployment
benefits there are a few coven 19
related exceptions
so the people aren't forced to choose
between their basic safety
and a paycheck but otherwise that's the
law
i know there's been a lot of discussion
since friday since friday's report
that people are being paid to stay home
rather than go to work
well we don't see much evidence of that
that
is a major factor
we don't see that that look it's easy to
say
the the line has been because of the
generous unemployment benefits
that it's a major factor in labor
shortages
americans want to work so we'll insist
that the law is followed with respect to
benefits
but we're not going to turn our backs on
our fellow americans
22 million people lost their
jobs in this pandemic through no fault
of their own
we still have eight million fewer jobs
than we did when the pandemic started
and for many of those folks unemployment
benefits are a lifeline
no one should be allowed to gain the
system
and will insist the law is followed but
let's not take our eye off the ball
okay so it's not it's not an issue but
here's the plan to
solve the problem that doesn't exist in
the first place
i agree with him that people lost their
jobs through no fault of their own i
mean that was like his fault the fault
of
of the democrat party largely in many of
these states
run by democrats especially that where
the lockdowns were uh particularly
strict and in some cases are still in
place
so i agree that it's not people's fault
they lost jobs this is the government's
fault that's absolutely the case
um which is why i've said from the
beginning that
i support stimulus payments
uh any you know unemployment
benefits for people who
lost their job because the government
took it away
as i've said all along that's an example
i think of an actual entitlement
the problem generally speaking with what
we call entitlements
is that oftentimes the people receiving
those benefits
aren't really entitled to them so
entitlement is
kind of an ironic label if you're
entitled to something it means that you
you're owed it
i'm owed this well in many cases the
people that are getting entitlements
they're not really owed that and if they
are owed it
who who who is in debt to them
in this case when the government comes
along and for no good reason
takes your job away takes millions of
jobs away all at once destroys your
business
destroys your entire industry in some
cases
um you are entitled to restitution for
that i would say from the government
uh so that is true but
it's also true first of all that we
didn't give
this entitlement only to people who were
actually entitled to it
we gave we passed out millions and
millions of checks
worth billions and billions and billions
of dollars
regardless of whether or not someone
actually needed it or not
there was there was no attempt made i
know it could be difficult
to do but these are difficult times and
so you got to do the difficult thing
it's difficult to first figure out who
actually needs the money who lost their
job and to target it that way
difficult to do it's worth doing because
the other option is just to give the
money to everybody
and that means it's gonna be billions of
dollars wasted for no reason
and that's what we did but even for the
people who really need it the fact is
that there is a there is a
attention here there is a problem when
you ins when you pay people not to work
when you incentivize not working then
they're not gonna work
and you're gonna have a lot of people
staying at home and living off of the
government
and we're not just talking about mothers
who you know now they're a single-family
household and the father is working it's
like not like that we're talking about
entire households where nobody's working
and that's what happens when you
incentivize incentivize unemployment
i don't fully blame people either i mean
i have to think
okay if i didn't have a job and i'm
getting paid by the government
and the only job that i could really get
right now is something that pays me
less than what the government is giving
me
yeah i i would certainly be tempted to
just continue taking more money for
doing
nothing you can understand why people
would make that calculation
it's not unreasonable i don't think it's
right either but it's not unreasonable
so that's the issue and it's a very real
problem
but biden says we don't have to worry
about it because
if if you're if you're offered a
suitable job you have to take it
and if you don't take it then you're
going to lose your unemployment benefits
there are so many ways around that
it's hard i don't even want to say that
there are loopholes it's not loop the
entire thing is one big hole the
entire policy is one big pull hole you
march right through it
it's not like loopholes you have to
sneak through
because who who decides what a suitable
job is that's up to you to decide
can you just say well that wasn't a
suitable job by my estimation
and how's the government going to know
that you are offered a job and aren't
you actually only going to be offered a
job if you go out and look for one
are they requiring that you go out and
look for one how are they requiring that
how are they
checking in on that how are they
confirming it
obviously there's no real way to enforce
this
and if there is a way to enforce it our
government is not interested in doing
that and isn't capable of doing it
again this is the same government that
couldn't be bothered or claimed it was
unable to first find out who needed the
benefits before doling them out
now we're supposed to believe that they
have the capacity and the interest in
enforcing um these kinds of policies
not gonna happen just not gonna happen
all right next we've got there's some
controversy after the horse that won the
kentucky derby turned out to have banned
substances in its system the horse is a
junkie basically just a total drug
addict
and here's the horse's trainer on i
think this is on fire this is on fox
news
addressing the controversy and claiming
that the horse is a victim
of cancelled culture let's listen will
you
run a medina spirit this weekend in the
preakness i know you have said that but
they're going to have a meeting tomorrow
down there at that race
no actually they're uh they're on their
way right now they're in a they're in a
band they're
they should arrive this afternoon and
we're definitely planning on running
them
i'm actually i'm going to run two horses
okay
bob here's my understanding they were
going to have the draw today for the
preakness
and they've kicked it back until
tomorrow um
you have another review those results
may not be available for several weeks
so the preakness goes down this weekend
the belmont is here in new york four
weeks from now
i i don't know if we have final results
even before the belmont is done but your
plan is to race in the preakness
is there a chance they may punt and not
allow medina's spirit to run this
weekend
well i haven't heard anything officially
they haven't told me anything
uh i know when churchill downs came out
with that statement that was
pretty harsh and i think they had to
just you know
it's you know with all the noise going
out you know we live in a different
world now this
this america is different and uh that
this
it was like a canceled culture kind of a
thing so they're reviewing it
i haven't been told anything i'm uh
we're prepared to run
uh i can't see but under the rules does
your team get to review the results
or is that left with the horse officials
no it goes there's a long process it'll
be a split sample
and then there'll be a hearing and this
it's going to take months this is going
to
this isn't done within a week and uh it
it's a long period
but you're here to say that bob
baffert's team did not
cheat to win the kentucky derby we did
not cheat to win the kentucky derby
okay that was a lot more information
about horse doping than i really cared
to hear
uh and i have no opinion whatsoever
about whether or not this horse is
guilty
of doping i don't i don't know what that
entails
uh i don't care at all but
what i do care about a little bit is the
claim there of
cancel culture and the reason i care
about that is the canceled culture
is a real thing it's a real
problem in our culture right now
uh many people's lives many people's
actual human real lives not horses
like horses can deal with it you could
you could shame a horse publicly shame a
horse
cancel them you could even take their
jobs away
and they'll they'll probably be okay
because they're still gonna be a horse
at the end of the day
uh until we turn them into glue or
whatever if that's what we're canceling
if that's if that's how we're canceling
the horse and i would say that maybe is
a little bit harsh
um but there are real human beings who
have been canceled
and their lives have been destroyed big
big problem
but when we abuse this term and overuse
it
as we see all throughout society same
problem all the time
but the the label loses its meaning
because we've applied it to too many
things
and that's what i really hate it now
anytime someone's backed into a corner
like this guy is
and you can kind of see his his heart's
not even fully in it
he's he's kind of grasping for an excuse
as i said i have no opinion on whether
or not he's guilty or whatever i don't
care
uh but he's grasping for an excuse he
said you know
it's society is like this right now it's
the thing with society and
uh and it's a cancer culture you know
yeah yeah it's cancelled culture that's
what it is
it's a culture it's a yeah
no um if this is not this is not
cancelled culture this is
you've been accused of doing something
maybe you did it maybe you didn't
people are kind of upset most people in
the horse racing
world care about it nobody else outside
of it does that's a normal thing
like at any time as long as there's been
horse racing
you know there are going to be
controversies like this so this is not
because of cancel culture this this
hasn't been affected
it's not like the can the controversy is
amped up now because of cancer culture
this controversy is probably what it
would have always been even without the
advent of canceled culture
cancel culture is entirely different
deal
and it is as i always say it is a
left-wing
phenomenon because most of the time it
is about using
institutions either calling for
institutions to punish
someone or those institutions actually
doing it punishing someone
de-platforming them
firing them maybe even arresting them as
the case may be
but is using the power of institutions
to destroy someone's life
along with your standard kind of public
shaming and all of that
all right uh we also have this axios
interviewed the ceo of glaad
which is the gay and lesbian what is
that alliance against defamation i think
is what it is
lgbt activist group and she talked about
how
social media companies are unsafe very
unsafe
for lgbt people and she's uh and
we got to do something about that all
these unsafe now what does she mean by
that how is it unsafe
what should we do about um these unsafe
conditions
well she explains that sort of here
so you created a social media safety
index
and so the original intention was to
give each of these facebook
youtube twitter tick tock a grade and to
say
here's how you're doing that didn't
happen why we did
come out with grades initially
internally and what we realized was it
wasn't the right
starting point the right starting point
was to give them the information to
act and give them a road map to be
successful
this is about less watchdogging
more partnering with these platforms to
get it right
what we ended up realizing was that if
we started grading
they'd all fail quite frankly you found
them all to be
unsafe in different ways they are
categorically unsafe
across the board yes we're looking for
real
concrete changes in the next year and
thereafter
and i think we live in this space quite
frankly
between government which is going to
take a very long time to put in
regulations
and these social media companies who
have the road map
but are not enacting it and in the
middle of this
is the lgbtq community who is being
profited
off of by hate speech and harassment
and we needed to step in quickly and
make sure that our community is
protected
not gonna make any comments about the
interviewer there
we'll move on to the woman who the the
president of glad who is uh
uh kind of this is what tyrants look
like and sound like now
first of all using the phrase quite
frankly a lot it's like it's a common
thing among them
but she says oh we want to walk
alongside
you and uh we want a partner this is not
about us
controlling no no no we're gonna partner
with you we're gonna walk alongside you
and take your hand
and grab it and not let go and
guide you with however much force is
necessary to the path that we have
decided you need to walk
but it's partnering don't let go of my
hand
that's the kind of partnering they're
talking about now i said she explains
what uh what she means by social media
being unsafe for lgbt people
that is false advertising on my part she
actually doesn't explain that at all of
course she does because they never do
and that's really the point
because if they don't define it then
then in any given situation they
they want to be able to define it
situationally whatever the situation
calls for
they don't want to set clear boundaries
of like
this is what is an unsafe thing for an
lgbt person
they just want to be able to because
really what this is obviously about is
shutting down
uh dissenting speech people who fail
it's not just people who are
it's not not even just people who
actively disagree with the lgbt agenda
obviously they want to shut you down
but if you fail to offer
the appropriate amount of applause and
you fail to have the appropriate amount
of enthusiasm while giving that applause
then you get shut down for that too
because that's also unsafe
because that makes people feel bad about
themselves
we just cannot stress enough how
talk about dangerous okay this is
actually dangerous
when we start when speech
and opinions are labeled
unsafe
successfully that's the real danger zone
because we've always been told we all
grew up with this idea
sticks and stones right people can say
what they want they can believe what
they want as long as you're not
physically harming another person as
long as you're not causing harm to
another person
then you're well within your rights uh
right it's the the old thing about how
your fists can
travel as far as your right to move your
fist ends where my nose is and that kind
of thing right
um and what they want to be able to say
what people like
over glad want to say is that they they
still believe that
that of course you have the right to
have whatever opinion and express
whatever views you want
as long as you're not harming another
person
and then what they quickly add is that
oh by the way a lot of your opinions do
cause harm
how do they cause harm what kind of harm
is it doesn't matter
we don't have to explain that to you in
fact asking us to explain it
also causes us harm
all right let's move on now to reading
the youtube comments
first comment says when i received my
license my parents instructed me that if
i get pulled over i am to say
yes sir no sir and to obey all
instructions
yeah that's the i got the exact same
speech
from my parents of course we're told
that this is
this is the talk that uh only black
parents have to give their kids but
i i can remember getting the same talk
from as a white kid i got the same talk
from my parents
if you get pulled over be respectful to
a police officer
it's not going to do you any good to be
disrespectful and also you know my
parents were of the opinion that
as kids we should just be respectful to
all adults in general whether they're
police officers or not
probably good advice in general
orange banana says hey matt sauna is a
finnish word
we're continuing this controversy from
yesterday sauna is a finnish word in the
finnish language each letter is
enunciated so it is pronounced
sauna if you did go to a finnish
sauna and pronounced it that way they'd
be impressed and might even give you a
deal for saying it properly
well i would never be in a finnish sauna
or any other kind of sauna
but i refuse that is one word even if
you're correct i don't know if i believe
you that it's pronounced sauna
heading over to the sauna today i don't
know if i believe you
but if you're right this is one of those
words where
i think the right thing to do is to
mispronounce it because the actual
pronunciation sounds weird
kind of very similar to when i go to get
a gyro i'm getting a gyro
i know it's you could say it's
pronounced euro or whatever
g-y-r-o gyro
sounds better it looks better that's how
i pronounce it
usually i'm all about protecting the
integrity of of
of language but uh there are some
exceptions
whenever i decide those exceptions are
that's what they are
uh matt how do you get to the point
where you don't care how many people you
offend i'm almost there myself but i
still have a guilty conscience
when i hurt somebody's feelings
i guess for me i can't really give you
the how-to process for me it's been a
it's
been really just a process of of being
numb
when everybody is offended all the time
by everything you say
and you've got hundreds of people
tossing labels at you and calling you a
bigot and so on and so forth
every single day eventually you become
numb to it
and you simply don't care anymore and
i'm
i'm certainly at that point
but at the same time and i think we're
at a
we all have to get to that point where
you don't care about the labels that are
tossed at you
and the opinion of the peanut gallery
doesn't mean anything to you i think in
order to survive we all have to be that
way
now speaking of canceled culture in this
cantoculture world we all have to get to
that point
because if you allow yourself to be
manipulated by those sorts of things
then you're never going to speak up at
all
so i do think it's a necessity but
i would almost call it a necessary evil
in a way
because you know in a perfect world
that's not actually a healthy way to be
it's not great psychologically i realize
that about myself psychologically i
don't care about other people's opinions
at all it doesn't mean anything to me
and so i could have a thousand people
screaming at me and so upset and it
would it just means
nothing i don't care i sleep like a baby
but in a perfect world i probably should
care
it's not really natural to not care we
are supposed to care about what other
people think and say
we're human beings we're social animals
so to be completely
numb to it it's ultimately not
psychologically healthy
but it is necessary these days
so it's kind of a necessary evil
um andre says lmao at matt confusing
tupac with biggie
when did i do that a few people in
comments accuse me of that i said that
uh
that p diddy killed tupac
which i don't know if that's true
allegedly that's the conspiracy theory
so i didn't confuse them at all are you
saying that you think he killed biggie
too
i haven't heard that one he just killed
them all maybe he did i don't know
um and joshua says your rap music causes
violence argument
is no different than video games cause
violence
it is different for all the reasons i
gave yesterday
i would put video games more video games
are a separate distinct thing from
music and movies but if i had to put
them in one category or the other
i think they're more in the movie
category certainly than the music
category
with rap music there is the explicit
encouragement
you are directly romanticizing this kind
of behavior
and encouraging it and also the rappers
themselves claim
repeatedly and passionately that they're
not making this up this is how they
actually
these are things they really did even
jay z who's like
67 years old now and worth 50 billion
dollars i might be exaggerating slightly
but he's still when he's rapping he's
talking about when he sold
crack 46 years ago that's all he's got
to talk about
he's been rich forever he's been he's
been a rich
multi-millionaire for way longer than he
was poor
um and but he he
the only thing he could think to talk
about the only thing in the world that
he finds worthy of discussion
still is bragging about when he was
selling crack and also bragging about
how rich he is now
that's it oftentimes that's just that's
how rap music is that's all it really
has to offer
there may be some exceptions but not
many
and so that's the difference rap music
presents itself as
not fictional even when it is
and you are and the the rapper is
explicitly directly romanticizing and
encouraging this behavior
film is different because it's clearly
fictional most of the time
and in many cases even if there's a bad
guy doing bad things in the movie it's
not being
it's not being encouraged like that the
bad guy is the bad guy and he's being
presented that way
and i think that's probably the case
often times in video games though not
always i also don't play video games so
it's hard for me to speak but i would
i would probably say video games belong
more in the film category
now a word from beard supply listen
there are a few facts
about beards and these are these are
just this is science folks this is
scientific facts
one is that this has been scientifically
proven that
uh men with beards are more attractive
to women
i think i think they're i don't have to
quote you the studies i just know that
they've been done
and also i think men with beards have
more uh moral worth
uh have have and i think that should
even be reflected in our laws we should
have
you know certain rights and dignities
that are not afforded to to average
people those are all just my
views of beards the point is i'm a beard
advocate beard supply might not agree
with all that but
they are all about helping bearded guys
look bet look their best
and look manly men grow beards they
grill meat and they drink handcrafted
booze that's
those are also facts scientific facts
and thanks to the manliest giveaway ever
some lucky guy will be doing
those things for free enter to win a
stash of goods from beard supply meet
church
desert door howler brothers and more
badass brands for the red-blooded
american male
one lucky winner will get a collection
of beard oils and grooming essentials
tools for grilling and leather care
and a 200 gift card for an outdoor
menswear shopping spree you get all of
that you can up your man game with this
stash of goods but don't delay
the beard supply spring giveaway is
ending soon so get on over to
beardsupply.com
giveaway to enter that's beardsupply.com
giveaway
and good luck also if you own an apple
device i've got some good news for you
all of the daily wire's latest news
commentary and analysis is now available
on apple news so we cover everything
that you're not getting anywhere else
if you want to make your news feed
infinitely better just head to apple
news on your device search for the daily
wire and hit the follow button it's as
simple as that
now let's get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we turn
our gaze to a woman called test holiday
a morbidly obese woman who identifies as
a model
holliday has been a plus size model and
body acceptance advocate for many years
she feels very strongly that obesity is
a wonderful thing
and we should encourage more of it
basically test holiday will be dead
before the age of 60 and she very much
wants you to join her
in this act of suicide and i understand
that may seem like a harsh way of
putting it but
encouraging morbid obesity is an awful
dangerous thing to do
and i think we need to be very
exceedingly clear about that
test holiday is easily 200 pounds
overweight
from the looks of it maybe more than
that nobody gets to that point naturally
nobody is born that way that isn't a
thyroid condition you have to spend many
years
eating a lot of food and getting very
little exercise in order to achieve that
sort of size
and that's why we have in the past and
should continue to put a stigma
on morbid obesity yeah there should be a
stigma it's not the look
that we're stigmatizing it's sloth and
gluttony
which is what leads to morbid obesity
why do we stigmatize sloth and gluttony
well because
that those qualities will make you
miserable and unhappy and unhealthy and
eventually kill you
so yeah we should stigmatize it so when
we say that tess holliday is an obesity
advocate what we really mean is that she
advocates the behaviors
the self-destructive suicidal behaviors
that lead to obesity
and for that she should be thoroughly
shamed and condemned
she doesn't care about body positivity
anyway much less self-love she is merely
trying to justify and feel better about
her own vices
by encouraging others to join her in
them misery loves company
it's a truth as old as time now these
are all true statements
about test holiday but we we were never
supposed to say any of that
out loud and and now we're even more so
supposed to shut up about it given that
tess holliday
has found a new way to make a victim of
herself the morbidly obese woman
announced on twitter a few days ago
that she's in recovery for anorexia
and we have to say that her recovery
appears to be going
pretty well here's what she said reading
from the daily wire article it says plus
size model and fat activist tess
holliday revealed last week that she has
anorexia and is in recovery
quote i'm anorexic and i'm in recovery
holiday wrote on twitter on may 1st
i'm not ashamed to say it out loud
anymore i'm the result of a culture that
celebrates thinness and equates that to
worth but i get to write my own
narrative now
i'm finally able to care for a body that
i've punished my entire life and i'm
finally free
and then she continued not the but your
fat how are you anorexic comments y'all
don't know how science and bodies work
do you
my technical diagnosis is anorexia
nervosa and yes i'm still not ashamed
i'm too damn happy for y'all to even
come close to dimming my shine
responding to criticism concerning
holiday's body acceptance active in
activism she said quote to everyone
saying that i can't possibly love
myself and have an eating disorder that
is an action that is the actual
definition of loving myself being able
to
prioritize myself and be in recovery i'm
more self-aware than any of my critics
but you know y'all go off
an instagram post holiday similarly
talked about her weight and scolded
people who tell her that she looks
healthy lately
quote to everyone that keeps saying
you're looking healthy lately or you're
losing weight keep it up
stop don't comment on my weight or
perceived health keep it to yourself
thanks
periods in between all those words
um okay now yeah don't comment on test
holiday's weight
none of your business i mean tess
holliday poses half naked in front of
cameras every day talks about her weight
brags about her body constantly shares
all kinds of information and imagery
with the public
that none of us asked to know or see i
mean we're trying to go about our lives
and test holiday is always running up
with a bull horn shouting hey guys
let me tell you more about my body
anyone want to hear
and yet it's none of our business we
aren't supposed to talk about it
well perhaps test holiday needs to
choose a lane here
if you're a private person living your
everyday life minding your own business
and somebody comes up to you as you walk
down the street and tells you that
you're fat
then sure that person's probably a bully
but if you go up to someone else
who's minding their own business and say
hi i'm fat isn't that great
they are well within their rights to
respond and say no ma'am it's not great
it's not attractive it's not healthy
and you're going to die soon you might
not like that answer but you brought it
up don't want to hear the answer then
don't bring it up
this is a this is the rule anything you
say to me
anything you bring up to me i am allowed
to have an opinion about
if you don't want to hear my opinion
don't tell me
if you don't want to hear the public's
opinion don't tell the public
but what about this claim that she's
anorexic i mean how can that be
good morning america did a segment on
the issue a few days ago where they
interviewed
test holiday and here's what she said
about it
this morning supermodel test holiday
revealing her struggle with anorexia
the mother of two saying she was
recently diagnosed by a psychologist
but has ultimately been struggling with
disordered eating
most of her life i always thought that i
over
ate but then people in my life would say
oh yeah i eat more than tests
and it was almost like i wore it as a
badge of honor
known for loving and celebrating her
curves as a body positive
activist holliday has been receiving
support for her honesty for many
but also being questioned by some online
about how she could love her body
and also have an eating disorder i've
had a lot of messages from
folks that are anorexic that are livid
and angry because they feel like
i'm lying i am plus-sized but advocating
for diversity in larger bodies and so i
think
for people hearing me say i'm anorexic
was
really jarring holiday's dietitian anna
sweeney says
if you think that most eating disorders
are visible conditions
you're wrong eating disorders don't have
to look
a certain way i understand that people
look at me and i don't fit
what we have seen presented as you know
the diagnosis for anorexia
but then for me that tells me that
there's
a larger problem which i've been
actually saying for years is that
we have a like a lack of diversity and
representation in the world
oh my gosh we need more diversity and
representation
in eating disorders that's what she just
said
for too long skinny women have been
getting all the anorexic attention
tess holiday believes that she's owed
some of that attention too
why should they be getting this
attention i'm here well i want attention
too
she believes that she's owed attention
for being too fat and too skinny at the
same time
she also seems to think she's stumbled
on a good excuse here she says that
she thought she thought she was
overeating and frankly the evidence for
that theory is pretty good i have to say
but
then she realized that she's anorexic so
if anything she's under eating
it's a clever trick you have to admit
now obviously a 300 plus pound woman
would not qualify under any coherent
definition of the term
as anorexic the the very term anorexia
comes from the greek
meaning without appetite that's what
anorexia means
without appetite that is evidently
not test holiday's problem but anorexia
is a mental illness and as we've
discussed in this segment a few times
recently
mental illness is a category
experiencing its own
um rapid inflation shall we say
a great many mental illnesses are simply
medical labels for normal
human behaviors and even many of the
ones that describe some kind of
legitimate condition
have been expanded now into near
meaninglessness
anorexia is the perfect example listen
to the latest definition of anorex
anorexia provided by the website
nationaleatingdisorders.org
okay this is what they say quoting them
to be diagnosed with anorexia
or rather anorexia nervosa according to
the dsm-5
the following criteria must be met
one restrictions uh restriction of
energy intake relative to requirements
leading to a significantly low body
weight in the context of age sex
developmental trajectory and physical
health
intense fear of gaining weight or
becoming fat even though underweight
those are the two actually so there's
the low low
low body fat and then also the intense
fear of becoming fat those are the
two classic definitions for anorexia
so far so sensible that's what you
imagine when you think of an anorexic
person right
underweight little appetite not eating
much
afraid of getting fat etc but then
there's the third definition
added recently also this
quote disturbance in the way in which
one's body weight or shape is
experienced
undue influence of body weight or shape
on self-evaluation or
denial of the seriousness of the current
low body weight
well there it is undue influence of body
weight or
shape on self-evaluation in other words
everyone is anorexic did you know that
you're anorexic so am i we all are
welcome to the club every single person
on earth is anorexic
because it could be argued that all of
us at least one point or another
have been overly concerned about our
body weight or shape
what counts as undue influence i mean
how much influence is due and who
decides that
who decides when it's undo well nobody
does it's all subjective it's all
arbitrary
it's a one-size-fits-all label that's
the point
we live in a culture where many people
are desperate to be victims
desperate to relieve themselves of the
burden of agency and self-determination
unfortunately the medical industry is
more than happy to oblige
which is how test holiday gets to be a
morbid obese potty
body positivity advocate who brags about
her obesity yet at the same time is not
responsible for obesity
because somehow it's a symptom of a
disorder which for everyone else causes
a catastrophic loss of body weight
it doesn't make any sense at all no
sense
but it's not supposed to this is what
makes test holiday
feel the best about best about herself
and her choices and that's all that
matters
that's all that matters
so for that reason we have to say
that test holiday today is canceled
and uh we'll leave it there and you know
for good measure to cancel the dsm-5
for like the fourth time in the last uh
week and a half i didn't even plan this
out
we spent much of the last week talking
about this problem
of how mental illnesses are being
expanded and then this is the story
today
there you go hate say i told you so
actually i don't i love it but
anyway test holiday is cancelled we'll
leave it there for today
have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. california
shrinks for the first time ever
a fat activist claims to have anorexia
and a uk pastor gets reported to the
terror watch list
for questioning the left's weird sex
plans check it out on the michael
knowles show